but right now we wanted to start with a  fatal crash this happened four hours ago  so the intersection of charleston and  pecos is completely closed police are  about to put this car on a tow truck it  crashed right into that light pole now  we sent our own photographer out there  and you can see exactly what happened as  investigators were on the scene this  would be between like three and four  this morning a complete closure of  charleston and pecos so how are you  going to get around back to the traffic  map for the detours pecos shut down go  east over to lamb west over to eastern  with charleston closed go north to  stuart or down to sahara meantime take